[Music]
hi i'm victor m sweeney victor is a
mortician and funeral director today i'm
going to break down clips from movies
and tv about dead bodies and just so you
know
there might be spoilers ahead let's get
into it decomposition from the movie
psycho
[Music]
if you look at mrs bates's face you're
going to see that her eyes have
completely decomposed i'm leaving only
the empty sockets likewise you'll notice
that her zygomatic arches that is the
cheekbones are extremely prominent as
the skin is tightened up desiccation
would be the breakdown of a body by
drying so we're talking about
mummification here mrs bait's a skin it
would probably be something similar to a
football it would be hard and leathery
this situation in norman bates's
basement would be incredibly illegal
most states have a system by which they
track a body from the time of death
until the time where they are either
buried or cremated setting the features
and cosmetizing the deceased from the
movie bernie you must cast the nails
to the person
you wouldn't want a mechanic to have the
nails of a flight attendant so this clip
gets so many things right it's very
important to remove any unwanted nasal
ear
or facial hair so we see bernie here
removing facial hair
and this is very important across the
board male or female ideally when
someone is in the casket we really want
them to look their best so for a man
that might include removing unwanted
nose hair or ear hair little dabble do
you
and it's no more peeking we see bernie
glue both the eyes and the mouth this is
a common practice not always necessary
it might be the case that eyes are are
not meeting correctly and you may need
to glue them but generally they'll abut
quite nicely and we must always be on
guard for the mischievous lip drip
you'll notice when bernie is gluing the
lips that they're kind of a grayish
color what that might show me is that
there is too much formaldehyde in the
solution and too little dye because
generally your internal dyes in the
fluid are what's going to create that
nice rosy color in a body and if there's
too much aldehyde it's going to create a
gray cast and what you really want is a
pink cast if it's already happened it's
too late and it would need to be
corrected by a lipstick or a heavier
makeup then apply highlights
do not over cosmetize this is great
because you see him actually warming up
some of the features you want to try to
hit the hot spots with makeup or lush
generally the forehead the lower ramus
that would be the the lower jaw you're
also going to try to hit the tip of the
nose and the point of the chin just a
note to always remember too much color
does not make one look more alive flying
body
mouse hunt it doesn't matter what color
it is
they're usually weight tested and
strength tested so this terrible
terrible thing doesn't happen to people
in real life you'll see that the casket
has what's called bail handles so they
have individual handles for each casket
bear typically you're going to see a
casket with what's called a swing bar
handle so it's going to be a rail that
runs the whole length
you can see the the light actually
poking through so that's going to tell
us that this is a non-gasketed casket
there's no seal around it it would also
be my assumption that it is not locked
the lid shouldn't be that wobbly which
is going to be a huge problem when you
see him totally destroy the hearse and
shoot up in the air
another odd thing about this
dad's not wearing any pants in the
casket it's common enough where people
don't wear socks or shoes but typically
in in an open casket situation you're
going to see at least the top of the
pants so i can't imagine they had his
underwear hanging out or his maybe dress
shirt tucked into them i don't know
moving casket
death at a funeral
the casket
should be locked the way it flopped open
tells me it's not it maybe shouldn't be
as easy to move as this shows
one thing to notice is that they have
dad facing the wrong way what kind of
mickey mouse business are these people
running anyway this will come into play
when they go to the cemetery for burial
let's say as most cemeteries are aligned
east to west with the head being at the
west end and the foot being at the east
that's why it's called a head stone
because it's typically on the west end
of the grave the reasoning for that goes
back a long way to antiquity where in
christianity they believe that the
second coming is going to come from the
east so that way if you were to rise out
of the grave your feet will be here and
your head will be facing
east as the sun comes up
cough and flop
from i think you should leave we showed
over 400 naked dead bodies on our show
cough and flop
every example in here is not a coffin
but a casket caskets are rectangular
while coffins are generally shaped like
a human the other issue i noticed
you see this clip where the gentleman
falls out of the side his head is on the
wrong side of the casket he should be
the other way around with the head on
the left side
in addition
there are a number of naked bodies
falling out of caskets which would lead
me to think that they can't be public
visitation funerals they must be closed
casket but then the question remains
why are they still naked
i don't know what to tell you bud
mortician's worst nightmare dropping a
body taking out the viscera
the haunting of hill house do you know
what i'm doing right now
i'm elbow deep in our sister's chest
cavity pulling out a bag of her internal
organs that's what happens when a body's
autopsy so this representation is pretty
accurate typically with an autopsy there
are two major incisions on the body
there's the y incision which starts at
the collarbones meets it at the base of
the sternum and then goes down all the
way to the pubic bone maybe not so
accurate that she cracks open the chest
cavity because in addition to making
that incision the chest plate that is
the breast bone is cut out as well so
ideally there's nothing to crack because
everything should be kind of wide open
don't talk to me that way we see her
that she's clipping through multiple
sutures
more often than not when you get a body
back from the medical examiner it's just
quickly stitched up because i know the
funeral director like me is going to
have to do most of the work in undoing
the body and then redoing everything
after the embalming so they don't take a
great deal of time making nice tight
stitches because we're just gonna have
to undo them again
that's what happens when a body's
autopsied and i have to take it out the
red bag that you see or pull out of the
chest cavity there is called the viscera
bag so this would include all the organs
that are removed from the body and then
studied by the medical examiner or
coroner
probably the longest task of embalming a
body that's been autopsied is typically
the suturing up of the body but then
also of the head what you want to
achieve is a nice tight suture so that
way you don't have any leakage or
anything like that coming out of the
body there's one method called the whip
stitch which is circular movements
around the incision in order to get it
nice and tight it doesn't have to look
good but it just has to be effective in
order to keep a nice good seal there's
another type of closure called the
baseball stitch so if you were to look
at a baseball you're going to see
threads going left and right and left
and right all the way down and almost a
chevron this is a great stitch it's one
of the most secure as far as leaks is
concerned cremation urn costs from the
big lebowski
this is 180
it is our most
modestly priced receptacle now 180 for
an urn that you would actually use in a
service is not an unreasonable amount
you know i would say typically and earn
might be even more than that but the
fact that the funeral director says it's
his most honestly priced receptacle is
probably not accurate generally at a
crematory built into the fees they're
going to have the cremation itself
and then the cremated remains that is
the pulverized bone dust is going to
come back to the family sealed in a bag
and it's going to come in an urn much
like this just a black hard plastic urn
that would be suitable for burial or
anything you really need no frills no
bells scattering the ashes but
especially if they're going to do as
they plan and scatter donny's ashes
there's no reason a family or friends
should be forced to buy an expensive urn
for something they're only going to see
just briefly and won't really serve any
real purpose for what they're planning
to do for a service just because we're
bereaved doesn't make us sad sir ideally
you as a funeral director are
doing your job beforehand to make sure
it never gets to that point not just
talking him off the ledge but making
sure he knows what he's getting so he's
not surprised and then angry about a
funeral bill that he can't afford
in accordance
with what we think your dying wishes
might well have been
later we'll see the cremated remains of
donnie scattered at sea in the big
lebowski here we will see a folger's can
being used but i have filled teapots i
filled cookie jars jewelry chests you
name it anything that could be suitably
used as an urn
is fair game
broken urn
meet the parents
oh ideally those cremated remains would
be sealed in a bag inside that urn so
when the urn itself broke the cremated
remains would remain intact in the bag
and this doesn't seem to be an
unreasonable amount of cremated remains
for a human it does tend to differ
typically the amount of cremated remains
you'll get back is based on the size of
the person but primarily on their bone
density so generally men will have more
cremated remains than a cremated woman
would it takes a lot out of him
embalming from the movie kissed
[Music]
welcome to embalming
ah that's more comfortable where to
begin okay right away you'll see the
gentleman is laying on the table his
head is not up he puts his head up
afterward his head should be up
almost from the time you pick him up
from the hospital his head needs to be
elevated to make sure the blood isn't
pooling in the backsides of his ears
also this guy is wearing no personal
protective equipment he's wearing a
smock yes and gloves but he's wearing
his daytime clothes he should be in a
gown in a smock over that two pairs of
gloves a face mask a face shield over
top a hair net and shoe covers and as
you can see he's wearing none of that so
if you were to have blood splatter let's
say that guy's shirt is getting ruined
the lid needs to be on that embalming
machine otherwise he's going to be
releasing formaldehyde gases into the
air jugular
is for draining
and the karates
for injecting i'll give the guy a little
credit he's right on that mirror carotid
artery is a very good artery for
introducing embalming fluid it's large
it's going to be rubbery and fairly
flexible and so as you're pumping fluids
in at a high volume and at a great deal
of pressure that artery is able to
withstand that he's also accurate that
the jugular is a good place to drain
from it's a large vein both of them up
by the neck so he would be accurate
there as well true car
many see it as the embalmer's sword
i hope funeral directors and embalmers
don't talk like that we suck out all the
ghoul
then we replace it with more magic
elixir that way our young friend won't
blow it up like a big embalmer's sword
and miracle elixir come on also he's
pointing it the wrong way typically when
you insert a trokar you want to go near
the navel and you actually want to go
upward first so you want to go into the
thoracic cavity and draw all the fluids
that are there first the reason being is
after you draw out the fluids from the
thoracic cavity you can move down to the
abdominal cavity without having to
remove the trocar and you're not
introducing let's say gut bacteria into
the thoracic cavity you're doing it the
other way around
what's happening is he's puncturing all
those lower abdominal organs he could be
puncturing through the intestines with
fecal matter and then what is he going
to do turn around and stick that fecal
matter right up into the thoracic cavity
or up into the throat that'd be terrible
you get used to the scale mortician
makeup
it's always sunny in philadelphia i'm
here
oh what on earth did you do to your face
i had it done at a funeral home for a
corpse
frank looks great for a live person
not so much you go to a funeral home to
get gruesome repairs most embalming
chemical companies will also have a
specialized makeup for the deceased
whereas most makeup is meant to go on
warm bodies this makeup is meant to go
on cold bodies you'll notice he has kind
of a pale cast to him look
ideally in the casket you don't want to
have that look because that's the look a
dead body will normally take on you look
like you're at your own wake
so in his case the mortician could have
just used a little bit of rouge you can
see he darkened around the eyes quite a
bit and that would be abnormal for what
i try to do you don't want to draw great
great focus to close dark eyes because
again that provides the effect of a look
of death and we want to avoid that if at
all possible i gotta get my makeup
redone glass casket
snow white and the seven dwarves
[Music]
historically full glass caskets or
coffins were not the norm at a certain
point in the 19th century caskets or
coffins might have a little window for
viewing so it's possible they'd have a
little door above where the face is and
there would be a pane of glass so you
could see your loved one without having
to open the casket today we don't often
have glass caskets although there are
companies that are starting to promote
the idea of plexiglas caskets so you can
get a full view of your loved one i
myself am not crazy about the idea
because every so often there are things
that go wrong with the body that you
can't control and you don't want that to
be on full display in front of a
grieving family there is always the
potential for what we call purge so that
would be the expelling from an orifice
of something that shouldn't be there so
you could have lung purge usually it's
like a frothy white color you could have
stomach purge which is generally the the
consistency of coffee grounds and you
could also have brain purge
and in a glass casket that might be a
major issue if that were to happen and
you weren't there to catch it gosh
that's a bad sign transporting the body
six feet under you grab your shoulders
on three
ready
one
two
three
this is a great example of how to throw
your back out probably the proper way to
do this would be to have one of the
directors roll the body and then there's
what's called a slider board it's like a
thin plastic almost like a stretcher
that can go underneath the body so we'd
roll them put the slider board
underneath lay them down upon the board
and then actually both of you go around
to the cot side and pull them off the
bed and onto the cot that way working
together the body becomes unshrouded
whoa and we see the gentleman has an
erection angel lust
does that happen a lot i've been doing
this since i was 18. i've never seen
that happen the only time i've ever seen
corpses have erections is actually
during the embalming process if the
pressure is up too high sometimes that
will direct fluid to the spongy tissues
of the penis causing a slight erection
and if that were to happen i would just
turn the pressure down and that'll
decrease in time
wrong dead body
death at a funeral who's this you know i
asked myself the same thing with my dad
pass i said who is this man no no brian
who's this in the coffin cause that's
not my father
oh
so it's certainly possible to put the
wrong body in a casket but a lot would
have to go wrong first okay
ideally even from the time you bring
someone from the place of death into
your care you are tracking who it is
every step of the way in my own
experience i'm in a small enough area
where i'm not dealing with
four or five deaths in a night so
getting people mixed up just doesn't
happen for me in larger areas where
maybe they have maybe say a central
embalming location it'd be extremely
important to identify and tag every
individual who comes through and that
could be done like by a toe tag in the
like in a morgue generally it's actually
just done with an ankle or a wrist
bracelet with the person's name and the
date of death then you're able to track
who is going where and at what time
because this is the kind of thing you
never want to have happen almost never
happens i said that a lot it's not
burger king you can't just mess up my
order i would be just utterly shocked
you think the first thing you're doing
something like that i hope it never
happens to me is you just fall on your
sword you just apologize you don't make
excuses and you make it right and it
might be that that funeral
is free i'm trying draining blood from
the body
final destination
the risk of cheating the plan
of disrespecting the design
could incite a fury that could terrorize
even the groundwater in this clip we're
seeing a specialized embalming tool
called the drain tube so we have on the
rounded end here this is going to go
down the vein we have to cut the vein
and insert this in the vein and then as
pressure builds in the body we can then
pull the end here and this stop
opens up and the blood will actually
pour out of the side so you're able to
direct the blood and then if you need to
decrease the flow or stop the flow or
open it up you have some control over
how much blood is exiting the body at a
certain time so that's spot on actually
the deceased has a drain tube in his
right
jugular but there doesn't appear to be
any sort of insertion for the embalming
machine now it's possible it could be
going into his femoral artery down on
his thigh but it just seems peculiar
that he's going to be draining blood
without
also introducing any fluids into the
system as well
the removal of the drain tube is fairly
accurate in this scene interestingly
enough we don't see any ligature so
there's no string at all typically when
we're embalming we want to have some
ligature to tie off those arteries and
veins that we're working with otherwise
you're going to have leaking right if
we've made a hole in the circulatory
system it's got to go somewhere ideally
he'd have those veins ready to tie off
he'd have the ligature there he'd pull
out the drain tube and tie it tight
taking a dead body
little miss sunshine
one of the many things wrong with them
taking grandpa through the window as
opposed to through the proper channels
is that the state wants to track where a
body is from the time they pass away
until a time of what we call final
disposition either burial on the ground
or cremation generally what's gonna
happen to grandpa initially they're
going to track the place of death which
would be in this case the hospital and
then they're going to have a transfer
permit which would be to the funeral
home so missing that step
there nobody's going to know where he is
until he gets back in the care of
someone with proper jurisdiction
so as far as getting a dead body out of
a hospital window i think they did a
really good job some points for
improvement winding that shroud a little
tighter would prevent some of that
floppiness if they had a little more
time to plan ahead it wouldn't be the
worst idea to have something firm
underneath him so they can make that
smooth transfer without him falling down
ideally they would want to put him out
feet first because then those in the
receiving end would have less weight to
carry initially and then they could even
rest his shoulder blades on the
windowsill before making that final
transfer
out
calling the mortician
the godfather
my friend
are you ready for doing the service
so typically people don't show up to me
bringing the body with them usually i go
to where the death has occurred in this
case
i feel very very bad for the undertaker
if it's good that he's making good on
his favor to the godfather so the first
thing we'd have to do is perform a very
thorough embalming with something like
this where you have multiple punctures
of organs certainly arteries and veins
you're going to have to make sure you
have a high index fluid so that would be
a fluid that has a more aldehyde than
normal because you want to make sure
that anywhere that fluid touches is
preserved and fixed then you're going to
have to make sure that you do a very
thorough examination of the body because
all of his extremities i would think are
not going to get as much circulation as
i normally would being that the fluids
going into the body are going to take
the easiest exit which is going to be
one of those many many bullet wounds
look how they mask with my book
preparing the body for an open casket
the haunting of hill house
we put her in her favorite clothes
and finally i take
extra special care to make sure she
looks just like she's supposed to
we're seeing in this clip this is called
a head block so this rests under the
head you can see it it's concave on two
sides so it provides
the ability to lift the head either
lower or higher depending on the
person's build what we're trying to
achieve when we use a head block during
embalming is we're trying to lift the
head up enough so that way when it rests
on the pillow in the casket it looks
natural instead of being perfectly flat
because then you'd have their chest
raising up along with their neck one
other thing you're going to notice too
is that the lady in the clip here her
head is tilted slightly to the right
ideally when someone is is laid out on
the table you want to have them looking
over the end of their right toe with
their head neither too far forward we'd
call that navel gazing or their head too
far back which we call star gazing we
want to have it just right in the middle
so that way they have a restful posture
and then their head tilted slightly so
that way when the family approaches the
casket they're seeing their loved one
face on instead of just their profile
from the side so when i'm done
she will look just like she always did
just like you remember her one thing
that she mentions to the boy that i
really really like is she's describing
what's sometimes called a memory picture
so one of the reasons we have open
casket funerals which may seem very
strange to other cultures and other
parts of the world is exactly as she
says we want to create an environment
that is peaceful and create an
environment where an individual can look
like themselves again burying a body
with their glasses
my girl his face hurts
and where is his glasses he can't see
without his glasses
put his glasses on you guys this is the
saddest
movie
but the scene is really great because it
does speak to the truth that you
normally see people with their glasses
on even though i'm not wearing my
glasses when i'm asleep and laying down
in the casket it's another thing because
you're usually looking at a person and
trying to make that image of them as you
would normally see in everyday life poor
thomas j you can see him here he's still
in the casket with the effects of those
bee stings that's one thing if i were
the funeral director i would work very
very hard to cover those up not that you
want to deny the fact that that's how he
died but his family isn't going to want
to see him with
the cause of his death all over his face
there are two ways that you can reduce
swelling in a body one way is to
actually weight down the swelling with a
soaked piece of cotton that would just
be soaked in water but heavy enough to
reduce that swelling to a flattened area
and then once the tissue is fixed then
it would not be a raised swollen area
anymore the other method is to actually
use what's called a tissue reducer so
this is quite an older model but if it's
not broke don't fix it but a tissue
reducer is basically a small iron and
you can see the foot on the end here it
gets hot hot hot and you actually would
use this in conjunction with some face
cream you'd put cream over the swollen
area and then use the hot iron to
actually iron out those raised areas so
it would cause the tissue to constrict
and then therefore the swelling to go
down it takes a fair amount of skill and
care to use something like this but in a
situation like thomas j here for the
family you would want to do everything
you could to decrease the swelling of
those bee stings
american military funeral
american sniper
[Music]
i would say in this clip they absolutely
had the military funeral down perfectly
so every veteran that passes away that
has been honorably discharged from the
military is eligible for certain burial
benefits these would be things like a
flag to drape over the casket it would
be military honors at the graveside and
that would include rifle volley so the
firing of the guns
it would include taps
and it would include the folding and
presentation of that flag to the next of
kin veterans are also eligible for
marker from the government for their
grave whether upright or flat whether
granite or bronze
[Music]
so
with the shooting of the rifles in this
clip you'll hear that often referred to
colloquially as a 21 gun salute but that
is actually technically reserved for
only the president former president or
heads of state so actually at the
graveside a veteran is going to get just
what's generically called a rifle volley
it could have seven riflemen it could
have two it could have one lowering the
casket the royal tannenbaums
[Music]
so i have to say that this ending scene
for a funeral is just fantastic
typically when a casket is lowered into
the ground more often than not there's
actually a device set up over the grave
to kind of automatically and slowly
lower it into the ground in this case
you see the family doing it manually
which i think is a good thing generally
anytime you can get a family to step in
and do some manual work themselves i
think it makes it all the more
meaningful in addition to that kind of
manual work families might put a scoop
of earth into the grave
fire we see the little boys firing their
bb guns in honor for their grandpa
probably my favorite part of this whole
thing is the absolutely false epitaph
that is on his headstone
i would love something like that for
myself someday my favorite epitaph i
ever saw had the person's name and when
they passed away and the only epitaph
was a good man and that's always kind of
stuck with me i mean that that really
should be the goal of all of us to just
be a good person and if that's all
that's said
all the better conclusion
being a mortician i think there's a lot
of stigma against morticians and funeral
service generally there's always the
idea that we are greedy or vultures or
preying on the vulnerable but really can
you think of many more professions where
people are working holidays nights and
weekends to take care of someone you
love on your behalf
as we're all going to experience or
maybe we've experienced already
death is a part of life and it's always
a fun and interesting challenge to see
it portrayed on film or in tv
you